what is going on everybody welcome to
part 28 of our matplotlib tutorial
series in this part what we're gonna be
talking about is plotting and connecting
lines with base maps so first of all
let's go ahead and choose different
coordinates here to start with we're
just gonna plot with the United States
so we're gonna change this to 25 this
will be 1 negative 1 30 and then 50 and
then negative 60 so that should give us
the United States yes
ok so we've done that we can probably
stop drawing the states well we can
leave them there
we were probably just up the Blue Marble
I suppose let's run that one more time
good ok so now that we've done that
let's talk about actually like plotting
some stuff so first of all after here
let's define some coordinates make some
space and what we're gonna do is let's
say for n yce
lat and then NYC long that's gonna be
equal to so New York City is forty point
seven north and then 118 West with some
decimals so forty point seven one two
seven and then because it's West
that'll be minus seventy four point zero
zero five nine I might have said 118 I
can't remember what I told you guys but
the other ones for LA so anyway this is
New York City okay now we have to
convert this so notice these are the
latitude and longitude so like I was
saying before lat/long is really YX so
at some point they have to be flipped
and here's where we're gonna do it we're
gonna say x PT y PT for X point Y point
equals M and then we pass through the
NYC long and then NYC lat there's where
our flip has occurred just for the
record now to plot these we can plot
them really simply by going m dot plot
so it's kind of like pi plot plot then x
PT y PT so we can save and run that and
we've plotted it although we don't have
a marker here so we need to add a marker
so kind of like matplotlib when you
first plot it wants to draw lines but if
you just have one point you're never
gonna see it so we're gonna change our
little marker so you remember like that
you could do that well we can also do
like let's say we want the marker to be
cyan and we're gonna have it just be a
circle that is filled in so let's go
ahead and run that real quick so New
York City now is being marked with a
little point on the map so let's close
that and we can do a few things here so
you can also do like a star so you could
do like a star like that there are a ton
of markers
and you can always go to like matplotlib
and like search marker types there's
just a ton of them you can do like a
triangle like this and plot that I think
we'll do a star though and then the
other thing you can add is marker size
so we can say marker size and say that's
15 so now you can really see it
hopefully right that's much larger let's
go back we'll make that a star let's say
New York City is our destination or
something now what we can do also is
like let's plot Los Angeles California
so we'll say LA lat la longue and that
is equal to thirty point four point oh
five and then negative one eighteen
point two five and then we'll convert
those again with XP te y PT equals M and
then la longue la lat and then again we
can plot those so m dot plot x PT y PT
and then we'll plot this one as I don't
know a green triangle and then marker
size equals 15 again okay
so let's save and run that real quick
just to get a look at what we're doing
so Los Angeles is here New York City is
plotted
air-cool so we've got these markers and
stuff but then what about how to like
what about connecting them so we can
close this and then what we can actually
do is we can we imply graphs no
different than any other way we've
plotted graphs in matplotlib before we
just need the X's and Y's so let's go
ahead and do that let's do X's equals
the list and then Y's equals a list and
now what we can do is once we've defined
x PT and y PT what we can do is like X's
dot append x PT
y's dot append y PT
and then do the exact same thing again
down here paste so we just copy and
pasted that now we can actually plot the
entire thing so now we can say m dot
plot X is wise so let's go ahead and run
that real quick all right so now we have
a line that's being drawn between these
two points now we can do all kinds of
stuff with this line we can do basically
all the things that we've done in the
past so we say line width equals three
we can also give it a label so we'd say
label and we'll call this will pretend
we're flying so we say flight 98 and and
we can also give it a color so we use a
color equals let's give it a color of
red so let's plot that real quick woops
what happened color of red comma all
right so now we've got that kind of
connection that's happening there
between these two plots so I'm gonna
close that now a lot of times with oh
the other team - let's go ahead and add
that legend before I forget so let's do
PLT dot legend so now I'll have a legend
and so it's like you know flight 98 the
other thing we can do is like change the
location as we've learned so like loke
equals 4 so now it's like down here kind
of out of the way of everything else
anyway so that's pretty cool now another
thing that we can do is kind of add like
a slight arc to the line so a lot of
times like if you're kind of connecting
two points I don't know
to kind of give it some flavor people
usually add a little bit of a curve so
what we can do is actually use this
thing called draw great circle so what
we can do here is that m dot draw great
circle and to draw the great circle you
give the court the first coordinates the
second coordinates and then everything
else like a line so the first
coordinates would be and these would be
in lawn and lat again so don't do that
long long lat
so we would do for example NYC long NYC
flat and then what was our other one la
long la lat and then we could leave it
that way for now and just so you can see
what I mean
so that now we've got like this arcing
blue line basically here we can close
that and we can now do color equals and
we'll make cyan line with same thing
three and then let's give it a label and
we'll just call it the arc so there you
go now you've got your graph you've got
your two connections here flight 98 and
this one's just like the arc basically
let's say so let's say you can start
connecting lines and obviously you could
just keep going connecting lines by a
coordinates the arc can only be between
two coordinates but as far as like
drawing these straight lines it's no
different than really any other you know
mapping and stuff so that's it for the
base map a little mini series here in
the next tutorial what we're gonna be
talking about is 3d graphing so another
topic we've kind of covered before but I
just figured might as well update that
series with everything else so stay
tuned for that if you have any questions
or comments please feel free to leave
them below otherwise as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions and until next time